welcome back to the David Pakman show I
am Benjamin Dixon filling in for David
David is away and will be back soon
you have me for the rest of the week so
if you're enjoying yourself so far
that's great news
if you're not enjoying yourself I don't
know why you wouldn't be but if you're
not enjoying yourself David will be back
sooner than you realize
let's jump into some more news we do a
lot of coverage of the President of the
United States because he is the
president of the United States and the
things that he says and does have
far-reaching implications yesterday on
Labor Day while the rest of us were
taking some time off to rest from our
labor this is what the President of the
United States said on Twitter he said
quote too long running a bomb Obama era
investigations of two very popular
Republican congressman were brought to a
well-publicized charge just ahead of the
midterms by Jeff Sessions Justice
Department two easy wins now in doubt
because there is not enough time good
job Jeff I don't think I have to explain
to you why this is so problematic but
just in case someone is wondering what
the big deal about this is is that
Donald Trump is implying here that jeff
Sessions should suppress an FBI
investigation into two sitting Congress
people and do so for political purposes
I mean this is this is unethical and in
fact this may very well be its own
version of obstruction of justice where
the President of the United States could
have implicated himself yet again in a
crime that is impeachable if there was a
Congress that would be willing to hold
him accountable
but because there's no Congress willing
to hold them accountable Donald Trump is
likely to get away with this and because
we become become so accustomed to the
President of the United States doing
obscenely ridiculous things on a regular
basis it's going to filter through our
news cycle without really moving the
dial in terms of public opinion there's
not going to be a bump down or
or otherwise when it comes to Donald
Trump because we have become accustom to
his madness to his complete lack of
regard for societal norms presidential
norms any type of decorum he is a maniac
and he has been unleashed only in the
United States and part of the damage is
that we have gotten used to it but just
so that you know of the people who are
involved with this Chris Collins
congressman he has been indicted on 13
counts of security fraud including wire
fraud and making false statements to the
FBI then you also have on the other hand
you have Duncan hunter who has a
well-publicized case not because Jeff
Sessions decided to pursue it but
because of what he spent campaign money
on and then how he got on television and
tried to blame it on his wife that's why
that became so well publicized in
addition to the fact that he allegedly
committed these crimes but just take a
look at some of these things or take a
listen to some of the things that he
spent money on family vacations to Italy
Hawaii and Las Vegas into the tens of
thousands of dollars personal items from
Costco 11300 and dollars personal items
from Walmart almost $6,000 in Walmart
and then he spent $2,000 to sin a family
member to a Steelers game I mean these
are these are the this is the type of
corruption that Donald Trump convinced
his followers that he was going to get
rid of and yet now on this side of it
he's lamenting because his
administration is actually doing what
they said they were going to do little
did he know that it was going to hit
people who supported him early on Chris
Collins or was the first sitting
congressman to endorse Donald Trump who
knew that a crook would endorse endorse
a crook I'm sorry I did I wasn't
planning on saying and saying that but
it just came out like that but it's the
truth
I want to read this quote from CNN on
your screen now quote a decision by the
Justice Department to hold off on
prosecuting two Republican congressman
up for re-election in order to help them
win would have been
highly unethical and a blatantly
politically motivated violation of the
department's nonpartisan mission so in
this case Jeff Sessions is actually just
doing his job and don't get me wrong
this is not going to make Jeff Sessions
some type of hero neither should he ever
become one because he has a standing
reputation and quite frankly is a
Klansman Keebler Elf ceman a keeper elf
King Landsman however you want to say it
and he is problematic and does not need
to be championed or lifted up as a hero
for simply doing the right thing in this
case but usually you know what I always
say whenever you see two monsters
fighting each other you sit back and let
them fight here's a tweet from former
attorney General Eric Holder and this is
what he had to say on Twitter he said
quote this is so dangerous and stupid
it's mind-boggling this is a fundamental
threat to the rule of law and here's a
tweet from former Deputy Attorney
General Sally Yates who was fired by
Trump this is what she had to say
repeatedly trying to pervert DOJ into a
weapon to go after his adversaries and
now shamelessly complaining that the DOJ
should protect his political allies to
maintain his majority in the midterms is
nothing short of an all-out assault on
the rule of law and I can't reiterate
this enough this is coming from the
highest range of power in our country
there there is there is no greater
threat to our democracy right now than a
president who is looking at the
Department of Justice as his own
political tool that he could use to
prosecute his enemies and to protect his
allies there is nothing else happening
in this country right now that that is a
unique change from the past
administration that is as damning and
devastating as what Donald Trump is
trying to morph his Department of
Justice into and this is not to make
Jeff Sessions a hero again he's not a
hero he's clearly not a hero but in this
case he's simply doing his job and seems
to be doing it
pretty correctly so far but I I'm really
I'm really loath to to give him too much
credit because it won't be long before
he uses the Department of Justice to
attack his enemies to attack his
adversaries so this is something that we
have to keep our eye on because the
president doing this little by little in
the public space makes us more
comfortable with it whether we are used
to it we may never be comfortable with
it but we have become accustomed to it
and and so it's not even alarming
anymore that the President of the United
States does something like this when in
any past administration this would be
the end of that presidency again the
best way I can describe it is that
Donald Trump has mastered the art of
having so much slime on him that nothing
sticks and we as a collective
consciousness as a collective body
politic have not figured out quite how
we are going to deal with a person who
has absolutely no shame and does not
seem to be able to be held accountable
for anything that he does